une cérémonie pour en faire le moment
fort de la journée et même du sommet
le président byden présente la
déclaration de los angeles sur la
migration visant à revoir la gestion des
flux migratoires sur le continent le
canada par exemple s'engage à accroître
son programme de réinstallation des
réfugiés des amériques et ainsi
accueillir jusqu'à 4000 personnes d'ici
2028 c'est sûr qu'on voulait faire notre
part on accueille des réfugiés qui
proviennent d'un peu partout à travers
l'amérique latine et des caraïbes et on
va continuer à le faire mais des absents
sur cette photo de famille porte un
certain nombre âge à la déclaration joe
biden estimait que les régimes du
venezuela du nicaragua et de cuba ne
méritait pas d'invitation le président
mexicain a décidé de bouder la rencontre
or ces pays sont à l'origine
d'importants flux migratoires c'est la
grande faiblesse
mais les états unis n'avaient pas
l'intention pour autant d'abandonner
cette idée de déclaration leur stratégie
c'est d'essayer de négocier des
adhésions en ce moment et même après
donc pour essayer de sauver un peu la
mise
justin trudeau a cherché à se tenir loin
de la controverse portant sur la liste
d'invités
même s'il signale son attachement aux
principes démocratiques
le canada est déterminé à travailler
avec ses partenaires pour améliorer la
résilience de nos démocraties si le
gouvernement trudeau dit vouloir
renforcer ses relations avec les pays
d'amérique si le premier ministre a
multiplié les rencontres
et là aussi réservé du temps pour son
principal partenaire économique
en plus de son entretien avec le
président joe biden il a aussi discuté
avec la présidente de la chambre des
représentants nancy pelosi
le canada est moins touchée par les flux
migratoires que d'autres pays d'amérique
en raison de sa géographie le
gouvernement trudeau souhaite tout de
même renégocier l'entente sur les tiers
pays sûrs qui permet les milliers de
passages aux chemins et roxanne des
pourparlers dure depuis des mois si on
ne sent pas l'urgence c'est peut-être
justement parce que ces entrées
irrégulières
représentent une goutte d'eau par
rapport aux mouvements de population
ailleurs sur le continent il si
madeleine blé morin radio canada los
angeles